oddio togliendolo a questo video
raggiunge 10 milano che ci proverò
anch'io fare questa trasformazione al
dittatore
oggi andiamo a fare un'altra reazione
quest'anno conservando ho visto questi
video su instagram sono rimasta
scioccata e questa sono ora li devi
vedere con lastre schemi dobbiamo
vederli assieme perché sono pazzeschi in
pratica si chiamano viral e il make up
transformation è praticamente sono
ragazze che si truccano ma non solo
usano che c'era e vari altri trucchetti
e si trasformano completamente la faccia
quindi andiamo a vederli assieme e poi
nei commenti mi direte quali vi lascio
cazzo si sono super minuto di vederli e
mi raccomando lasciato un bel like a
10.000 lights proverò anch'io
ok iniziamo con questo primo video non
so perché si è disegnata delle righe in
faccia
va bene vediamo che succede
a me sono condotti da un po più chiaro
addio
quest bianca te acqua perché capito è la
stessa persona
non capisco stata sotto popolose
invitiamo tutti gli occhi che sono
diventati enormi
ecco questa cosa che fanno dallo scotch
che si tirano la faccia quali altri come
i più alti completamente diversa ha
cancellato con del trucco dell'altro
trucco che c'era sotto ok ok vediamo
vediamo
già non so come fa nostri occhi
questa è la mia puntata ingrandisca un
giochino maniera assurda se togli anche
siamo più tante di terzi
incredibile come il viso era molto più
sottile ma questo si trucca navale
apposta per far vedere la differenza
vediamo quindi alcuni si sa che sono già
toccate si truccano e si vede come si
sono realmente invece altre si truccano
in ansia avere una pelle chiara è
sinonimo di bellezza come per noi essere
abbronzati non per tutti ovviamente un
po sinonimo di bellezza in avere la
pelle chiara per quello che sono sotto
un fondotinta super chiaro questa cosa
dello scotch ma è incredibile forate
quanto è di per sé la sua faccia era
completamente diversa
[Musica]
ok
ma
non capiterà mente
[Musica]
e questo sta toccando da teri preferisco
perché sono ancora più si no certo non
ci posso credere che sta una stessa
persona
e così prima per truccarsi wow
[Musica]
ok
insomma lo scotch e dal collo
[Musica]
marino nei guai soprattutto dietro la
pelle si sta togliendo la pelle indietro
o mio dio
[Musica]
oddio che si pensa alcune si truccano
male a posto all'inizio comprendere
l'effetto ancora più forte e credibile
troppo chiaro questo quando il team
vediamo vediamo la trasformazione è
bellissimo da vedere però che strano che
usano uno spray con il collo sono quel
metodo dell'acqua comprenda che fissa il
trucco
[Musica]
delle bamboline ma quale sembra che si è
scritta la faccia a posto adesso non ho
mi impressiona non capisco comunque sono
carini anche prima non hanno bisogno di
tutto quel trucco e di stravolgere
travolta non la faccia così tanto
qualcosa ne pensate che i temi nei
commenti
[Musica]
ecco perché una cosa dell'acqua forza
mi chiamo questa
[Musica]
come dimetterà
ha mangiato forse la cosa simile dai
quest'album touring
ad un altro livello proprio
bravissime ok vediamo questa ragazza
come riesce a patto che sopracciglia
wow
[Musica]
wow giochi sono proprio diversi questa
cosa dello scotch è pazzesco mi viene
voglia di provarlo oh mio dio assurto
sembra veramente un'altra persona ah ok
ho messo un po di sera ora harris
toccato così rivediamo l'aspetto
supporto sono scioccata sempre
fondotinta chiarissimo
[Musica]
mica qualcosa in bocca
questa lente a contatto sembrano da lì e
non volevo confrontarmi
diversa
scurto
[Musica]
ho detto mille volte ma è assurdo e
vediamo su x factor insomma
sempre le lenti a contatto si vede
perché no gli occhi molto più grandi
[Musica]
che strana sanremo con la parte finta
del nato come cosa
[Musica]
ciao
oddio
[Musica]
terra
cosa in testa
[Musica]
se non capisco perché bevo l'unico
come fanno a stamparsi sorprese
a me sono scorso guardate quanti partita
[Musica]
incredibile sono bravissime che prossima
vediamo un po le guance a me qualche mi
fa più strano sono le guance per
scompaiono
ecco il battito scomparse adesso mio zio
ma non so perché ha tutte piacere il
viso così schiaccia tissimo tutti i tipi
divise sono bellissimi
ovviamente ci si può valorizzare molto
con il trucco bisogna prendere un po
come un divertimento ma cercare di
cambiarsi completamente per sembrare una
persona completamente diversa
non penso che faccia molto bene voi cosa
ne pensate
massa
lei che ha contato a farlo un
cambiamento secondo lo stesso
penso che come esperimento sia
fantastico da fare e vedersi per una
volta completamente diversi ma no non ha
questa tappa di tutti i giorni ho da
fare spesso comunque poi milioni di
libri come ecco l'impatto dello scorso e
questo è quello che invece di più perché
è incredibile il cambiamento
incredibile sta facendo qualcosa con il
mondo tinta fa ci vuole nascondere le
labbra
una sfumatura ok vediamo in
trasformazione
questo abbiamo già vista quel poco tempo
che era tutto un sopracciglio
disegna ha disegnato le sopracciglia
niente di vedere questa wow sono
bellissimi da vedere in uno stop mi
incazzo a vedere queste trasformazioni
state questo per esempio per voi ad un
testo che strapotere l'assenza
materialmente ha raccontato mi butto
l'impressione
[Musica]
ma devo dire che comunque non è cambiata
troppo
che strano
assurdo non so se fa male puoi togliere
con lo scotch
[Musica]
wow
troppo bene
come faccio a pisa 3 10 volte più grande
è poi soccorso per sottile
[Musica]
o
ah ecco ci hanno dato
mi piace
perché fin qua nell'occhio
sapete che dopo abbiati quote
leggermente più stretto che devono fare
una cosa del genere
comunque per aprirlo un po di più per
renderlo un po più aperto essendo
appunto di occorre telo chiusi attico
poco poco più stretto secondo me non c'è
proprio bisogno perché no me lo chiedete
atc voi cosa ne pensate
[Musica]
mi fa stesso per sistemare il naso
[Applauso]
wow sono veramente bravissima detto il
card
nessun trucco
[Musica]
no
e quello che sconvolge più una forma del
viso quanto cambia
[Musica]
incredibile
vediamola sconfina
strano o poi non capisco perché
completiamo presidente o queste lenti
sono tutte
vediamo vediamo quest'anno lo scorso
quindi lo fanno scendere fino a qua
piacciono così
sì
poi mi piacerebbe più cosa che prima
sono struccate questi tool nuovo
comporre quel che sono già toccate
questi truccano a me quello che si
truccano perché la trasformazione
incredibile latte trasformazione ski
eventi bramante speravo e truffe
ok ragazzi di riprendiamoci qua anche se
io continuerei a guardarle per altri 20
minuti perché è veramente pazzesco e del
bellissimo dovere queste trasformazioni
fatemi sapere cosa ne pensate secondo
voi salsera troppo oppure ognuno libero
quello che ognuno è libero di fare
quello che vuole con la sua falsa ne
pensate fatemi sapere tutto nei commenti
e mi raccomando se volete che sperimento
lasciato quella ikea dissimile dai
sandro parlo e ora vi lascio fare 4
quadrati su cui potete cliccare per
vedere i prossimi video al tribunale nel
video divertenti cliccate su quello che
preferite e buona visione